I am joined by karl-thomas Neumann he is
the CEO of opal we have their new car
out the Astro behind us it's your profit
Center tell us about it and is it going
to help you return the profitability in
Europe yes it will be very proud about
it it's all nuestra we designed it from
scratch it is out small on the outside
but logic on the inside in to a nickels
lighter and it has innovations in it and
features so that we say it really annoys
the upper class oh the upper class the
upper class the rolls-royce browse
they're going to be able to think that
they're missing something on the table
exactly we bring luxury to to the
standard car to the ordinary car and so
we have features in here like massage
seats like ventilated seats we have
safety features autonomous breaking and
we do have a new light system which
doesn't clear the ongoing traffic but
it's much brighter with LEDs and we do
have a district are here it's fully
networked with onstar well does that new
light system won't annoy the chauffeur's
of the rolls-royce but we won't give we
won't get into that you want to return
to profitability in Europe you said
mid-decade everson update well the Astra
is designed to make money that's very
important to a lot of focus on it we
didn't change the entry price but we do
hope and we do think that we can
generate more money per car with all
these options and we are on track we are
committed that that we want to achieve
breakeven next year we never said it's
easy about we are working it and and we
be a successful so far so 2016 is the
calendar year you expect to break even
at the no comparable correct no
no no fudge on an obstacle well it is we
never said it's an easy goal and we had
our drawbacks like the russian crisis
like some epics effects which affect us
but we also had our successes beyond
that so the important thing is that we
are able to grow and that we can grow
the new cars which are profitable so
growth this will be the third year in
sequence where we grow market share even
though we exited Russia so we need to
execute the plan it's hard we are
fighting every day but we want to
achieve is the market share growth is
where you want it to be because yes
you're slightly up but it seems like
you're still struggling for market share
well we are we are you're right we would
like to see more but wash up the acid is
called the tribute here the think the
more important fact is that we can make
up for the issues russia in russia and
we can grow and we for example all of us
we grew by thirteen percent so it's
happening when we look at where the
euros at right now is that sustainable
is that a challenge where would you like
to see the gyro wrap for the year plus
follow up in a stronger euro would be
better and so let's see how things
develop something i cannot be influenced
so 120 130 how much stronger you needed
well the more the betterer for the group
it's a different picture because it all
this is kind of like naturally etched
but for all its important the strong
other you're all the better where do you
see the european car market heading in
the next two or three years we've seen
and come back to strength is it going to
continue to grow and how much of it is
artificial by steaming this cash for you
know cash for cars it is growing but if
we honest is growing very slowly yeah
because that's always something like
russia so it's going by a few percent
points but it's still way behind its
maximum 10 years ago so at some point it
should really start growing stronger for
us thus often european and eastern
european countries are really strong and
also the UK has been
a good market what's wrong for a long
while now some of those Eastern European
countries could be affected if the
Federal Reserve raises interest rates
later this week how concerned are you
about what the Fed might do and how they
affect auto sales here in Europe well I
think the key question is where I see
gonna be going and then what do people
feel about it to buy your car you need
some confidence in the future and we see
that any disturbance and the
destabilization is not helping us so
everything which leads us on a way of
stability is good for us so
profitability on the car behind us
where's the Carl doing how's it doing on
its profit very well Carl is obviously a
tough segment cars also depending on the
Korean Won very strongly because we
imported from Korea but we are confident
we can make this car work and actually
it's very successful in the market we
have one it's selling like hotcakes
you're winning awards correct well
you're not making much money on well you
never make much money on such a small
car but it's important to cover fixed
costs and it's also important because
this was the car where we got our
dealers into supporting us when we took
the chevrolet brand out of upmarket
where we have entry-level cars the car
is not playing this role and the places
at the dealers the the real estate the
flow place is now used for Robert and
some third party right